question from Kim Yuna who's saying for
me executions my Mount Everest because
I'm starting out on my own so you know
what advice do you have for solo
entrepreneurs we're having trouble
executing on their ideas because you
have to do everything from CEO to
janitor in their company yeah I think
you know if you work in adding a home or
whatever you're an entrepreneur key
thing is structure discipline and
routine so kind of even get out of your
pajamas get downstairs get your
breakfast get up early get every day
just almost imagine you're working in an
office creating a business from from the
get-go so and then from that I think
it's all about the bass Rex execution
bias traction so come up with your idea
that's good enough test drive it with
the community that you want to market
and sell it to you can do that you know
a number of different ways you could
kind of go down to the local coffee
store if it's kind of consumer idea you
could do it with your friends but the
most important thing is get your idea in
the market place if it's a product or a
service start actually getting your
first customer and it's almost like Evan
when I go back and I was in the startup
into California as an angel investor
there's momentous times especially if
you're on your own you need to celebrate
because sometimes you can have down base
it can be depressing so you know it's
like the first time you get your product
to market celebrate it you know open up
a bottle of spring water or something
like that whatever you want to do when
you win your first customer celebrate it
savor the moment and remember those kind
of milestones when you get your
hundredth customer when you get you know
a customer repeat referral where they
recommend you to other customers
celebrate these things because that
gives you great spirit it galvanizes
your energy and it reinforces your ideas
and then once you've got customers I
mean it's all about test drive in their
feedback build feedback into your model
from day one so that you're always
innovating you're your price almost like
with people what I'd say I'm Evan this
is pretty crazy there are people the
minimum standard has got to be better
than the best of our competitors and
it's the same with
products so as soon as you see
competitors trying to eat your lunch and
ketchup you've got a leapfrog to the
next level and just think that will be
good enough for the next 90 days because
in 90 days time I guarantee you need to
leapfrog to the next level again it's
just a constant relentless innovation I
love it I love it I love the passion
come on it's great thinking about you
know being a solo entrepreneur one thing
that I would encourage you to ask
yourself every day is what's the highest
value that I can bring to my business
and carve out time for what I call CEO
time where you're not just putting out
fires and reacting but you're purposely
planning what you want to do to grow
your business at least 90 minutes every
day of CEO time on big-picture stuff to
help you grow otherwise you're just
gonna stay on the treadmill and in terms
of celebrate I love that point I
remember when I was first starting out
and then had you know eating beans for
lunch every day and making $300 a month
when we had something big happen we
would go to McDonald's and we would
celebrate with french fries not of not a
whole meal because we didn't have the
budget for but just french fries and
that was our tradition of going out hey
we got a new sale let's go get some
french fries so it doesn't have to be a
big expensive party celebration you know
just just taking the time out to
celebrate is super valuable important
because it's hard to stay motivated
sometimes as an entrepreneur and those
little things can make a big big impact